c'est un tremblement de terre politique
en Amérique latine l'extravagant Javier
Miley ancien rockur et libertarien
revendiqué a été élu ce dimanche
président de l'Argentine et alors que
les instituts de sondage prévoyaient un
vote serré face à son adversaire et
ministre de l'Économie Sergio Massa ce
fut un rad Maré 56 % contre 44 % soit 3
millions de voix
d'écart c'est le mot d'ordre d'une
campagne haute en couleur qui a rallé en
moins de 2 ans la jeunesse et une classe
moyenne minée par la crise économique sa
promesse destituer la classe politique
corrompue qui a laissé l'Argentine
s'enfoncer dans la dette et une
inflation record de 138 % l'an passé sa
méthode la réduction drastique de l'État
et la suppression des aides sociales qui
incitent à la paresse Ministerio de
trabajo empleouridad social afuera
Ministerio de Educación
adoctrinamiento afuera
min travail éducation droits des femmes
ou encore solidarité et transport autant
de ministères parasitaires qui
entretiennent un pays d'assister et
qu'il a déjà promis de supprimer jaavier
my compte également détruire à la
tronçonneuse la banque centrale et
abandonner le PO argentin au profit du
dollar américain sur le plan sociétal la
liberté reste son mot d'ordre partisan
de la vente d'armes pour favoriser
l'autodéfense my plaide également pour
la légalisation de la vente d'organ
source de revenu potentiel pour les plus
pauvres il séduit aussi l'électorat
conservateur par son utilité à toute
politique de défense des minorités
sexuelles et ethniques et par sa
promesse d'interdire l'avortement qui a
récemment été légalisé dans le pays my
aime prendre des positions dures et en
rupture avec le consensus général il se
veut macho et se réclame de droite mais
il n'est pas conservateur il ne promet
pas l'ordre mais le
[Musique]
chaos